hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to resident evil
village
now that we have lady dimitrescu with us
at all times
in our heart and in my pocket which i'm
still not entirely sure how i fit the
gigantic crystal
that is lady dimitrescu in my pocket it
will be
like i'm always in the demon rescue dim
a dome hi bud
what is this guys the duke oven feel
free
find some quality ingredients and bring
them to me
well that's a new one that was not there
before
ah herbert fish
okay so i do have a reason to
murder all of the creatures around here
oh i also got a new gun right
i'm not gonna worry about this right now
okay so i'm i can sell this
i'm never selling this yeah no not that
there's definitely some combinations
that can go on there
thanks buddy whatever you say okay let
me know if you find anything else of
value
i will apparently there are treasures
about i'm going to do a quick
scan of the area back here for treasures
before i start moving forward
i'm also going to uh go back to this
thing because i i think it's still
better right now
than my other gun i'm not 100 sure no no
no no no but also i'm a big dumb idiot
who doesn't know how to play games right
so what do i know
if i am is a big dumb idiot then you
know
that's just how it gonna be okay i think
i can get back there
there's a couple things over here
bang give me your meat
give it to me haha you think you can
escape
i will take your delicious meat lady
dimitressko is hungry ladies
rescue wants to have a good dinner my
giveaway did about rescue what the
lady wants oh god oh they're extinct
well oh
it's and i have the key to ah
but over here there's something else
right i can't get in this place yet
right right right right right right
right right right right right
right right oh that has all the things
god damn
okay you know what screw it i'm not
gonna deal with it what's up big guy
shut up what would happen if i sh i'm
not gonna but what if i
did i can't i can't aim at him okay fine
whatever
i'm gonna go over here now four winged
key please
i will do my best to get treasures as
best i can
but i can't promise that in this
particular play play playthrough
that i will be able to do everything
that i
need to do oh this looks familiar i'll
do
this is what you would call bad this is
what you would call creepy
this is what you would call terrifying
bang
you got 420 bucks
that crow had 420 macaroons well don't
mind if i
do what's up with resident evil and
always hanging
things oh a pram
all right potter potter's field
scared potter yeah actually kinda
well that's just a return it's a return
back it means something's gonna chase me
okay all right hello
hi how you doing good to see you oh yeah
this is safe i'm charging ahead
ain't nothing gonna ain't nothing gonna
happen to me if i keep going forward no
nothing no no
no no nothing's gonna happen to me yeah
and i'm fine
thank you i knew i would
what wife
listen wife i met someone it's hard to
explain well it's easy to explain she's
twice your height
hey what's up ethan
come with me there's something i have to
tell you
sure what's going on yeah what's going
on am i recording
yes oh my brain is so cool you know
mia i saw you got shot like 29 times
you okay did you get better
this feels different yeah well she's
you have to fix her she's kind of in a
couple jars what the hell is this
i don't know i don't know what the hell
it is
i don't even know why the hell everyone
leaves me
even rose i don't want to be a little
well this can't be real i kind of didn't
have a choice
so what's the over under on ethan being
infected a little bit already
there's no way he's not but also how did
they let him
just live a life you know how did that
happen hello
ah beneviento
wonderful oh it's the dude it's a
musician dude isn't that the musician
dude what's with my
grave weirdo grave
uh to answer your question ethan yes of
course you're losing it but that doesn't
mean you're crazy
ah
well i forgot about the well wheel
well wheel give up your memories
oh ah okay here you go
hey take some of this there you go that
creepy baby anyway
yeah oh what's going on
well that was easy can i have that back
then i guess ah no it's just
mysteriously gone forever is that you're
trying to say to me
all right
squeaky uh-huh oh yeah this is
yeah this is normal oh yeah
oh yeah this is the good
[Music]
come with you well i kind of already am
going somewhere
so if that's not already coming with you
what's trippy
oh
okay fine
that's good that's good this is good
it is good feels good hey oh i thought
that was castled in the trescue
wow that's a biggen
that's a big boy waterfall that's big
hey whoever is the master of this place
is not nearly as impressive as castle
dimitriscu house beneviento just gonna
say
pretty underwhelming kind of not a lot
going
on kind of pretty unimpressive kind of
like
you know a little bit boring if you will
not nearly a tall enough doorways to
fit my magnificent grandeur
why is all these doors always heavy why
are the doors always
difficult oh that's a trap
oh yeah that's a trap that's a trap
well so far it just looks like a normal
ass house
not even breakable pottery what is this
garbage oh
okay
all right little bit spoopalicious
but not that spoopy like i've seen
spoopier so it's not like
maximum spoop [ __ ] oh
god i'm gonna hate this dude i'm gonna
hate this dude
i'm gonna hate this dude i can already
tell i'm gonna
hate this dude
i'm gonna hate this dude
i am
this is like tripping up my mannequin
phobia to an extreme
and i can tell him
i'm just gonna pull out my shotgun
i feel like i'm gonna need it
okay it's really quiet
okay
okay you know i kind of forgot this is a
horror game
staring longingly into uh the grand
halls of castle dimitrescu
often makes me realize that not
everything is
happy and go lucky in this game
terrible horrible terrible terrible
terrible and horrible
everything about this is terrible and
horrible
horrifying awful
this is the worst
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
i'm a brave man
i'm very brave
[Music]
i'm not that brave i'm jesus christ i'm
not that brave
okay all right
[Music]
okay oh
only if you turn yourself into a crystal
that i carry in my pocket
okay wait where's my gun
yeah where is my gun where's my knife oh
no
hello how are you this is terrible
this is terrible and terrifying
terrorful oh yeah
what am i doing
no what am i doing
what am i doing what am i doing
what am i doing
what am i doing why am i doing
oh no
why did i do that
can you it's believe
this is my neighbor oh
no oh no
oh no oh no
no no no no no why
why would i do this why
okay that's not normal
why um
what are you this is supposed to be mia
okay is this mia
well this is easily the most terrifying
thing i've ever done in
uh any horror game ever uh may not seem
like you but um
really hate it it really hit all of this
really hit every part of it
ah somehow that got locked well that's
good okay so it's like escape room
i'm getting that okay picking up that
that's good that's good this is all very
good
okay what is this hiding it's hiding
where do i need that don't
breathe so god damn love you [ __ ]
i hate this i
hate this words cannot describe how much
i hate this
okay interesting
interesting okay so three eyes closed i
remember seeing that on the
dummy's arm okay
looks like something could fit the
depression
yeah i know that feeling okay so i gotta
find like
symbols on this thing for some reason
what a lovely mannequin what a l yeah
touchy touchy touchy tucci tucha
oh that's cool
great i don't remember seeing anything
that needed to be wound up and
personally i feel like if there was
anything that needed to be wound up i
would not wind it
okay yeah i'll take that
cool this bloody ring
it is a bloody ring
what is wrong with you
uh examine the boobs yes all right oh
you know i don't want to
the bandits are tough i need something
to cut through them
you know what i'm okay
oh no
okay great don't stick your finger in
there
winding key something in the mouth i
need some kind of tool to get it out
yeah because i'm not sticking my finger
in there
not on your goddamn life
you don't get that close aha
interesting all right cool crow
well that's helpful for some reason
crow there you go
well this is great this is really cool
it's super dope ah
have a sip wash off this ring
cool all right should i examine the ring
i can guess
looks exactly like we we as we as
wedding ring
oh oh five two nine one one you got it
oh five two
am i free to go i guess i'm free to go
i'll kill you
okay my thread worked a memento of my
time with ethan
but this music box no longer plays your
time
with ethan what do you mean
why is this here yeah why is this here
how about a winding key
oh great okay let's listen to this
okay so something's not right how am i
supposed to know what's not right
oh the scratch pattern i see i see
okay okay okay there's distinct scratchy
patterns
i see let's try that
pretty good i'm pretty good
ah i can grab it out of dalmia's mouth
now
whatever it is i don't not like these
closets
i do not like the closets
hello excuse me
excuse me all right you know what i'm
going to go back anyway
i'll go open the goddamn mouth i'll go
pull whatever's in the goddamn
boop
[Music]
yoincus let me just tweeze my way in
there i use my telekinesis anyway
it's very good now
anything but what
hello
am i still recording i'm gonna go
to that project
who taught the resident evil people how
to make scary
decided to give them the goddamn right
the the freaking audacity of these
[ __ ]
i will kill you you are not what i
thought you were
i will kill you i will kill all of you i
will kill you
so good hello eat my key
hello are you i'll eat your ass
every one of you take this
our happy family rose's best friend in
the whole wide world
he really likes his fairy tale the most
important thing in the world i guess
a wedding gift from grandma proof of
ethan's everlasting love for me
well some
film okay we're going to move
this there proof of
wait what was it again what the hell is
this fairy tale
most important thing in the world does
okay okay okay so that was definitely
this
fairy tale most important thing in the
world to us
winning it from okay this looks good
okay so we got
favorite thing in the world story a
story like it most important
thing gift and proof of love
uh this not the movie i thought it was
going to be
oh it's the ring oh oh oh
okay that's cool too also great
i love that this is
i'll kill you okay cool
oh good oh good
oh god
what was that
i hate mannequins so much i hate
[ __ ] i hate
yeah okay yeah this snip
snap snup [ __ ] let me through
[Music]
where am i i don't even know i don't
even know
yeah this yeah okay all right good thing
hi
yes hello i would like pizza
okay thank you okay
okay oh now
do you know about alkaloid plants
mia what are you talking about i love
you both so
much i had to i
had to do it had to do
it okay so that didn't sound like uh
oh no i cheated on you or something like
that that sounded like uh oh my baby's a
horrible fungus baby
and uh went through the umbrella
corporation to make a super
super fungo baby so
it's as i suspected that baby's freaking
weird
and uh oh interesting huh okay
well this is great so many things could
fit my depressions you know
so many things well all right
unlocked
i'll kill you i'll kill you i didn't die
did i trip over a chair or what happened
please tell me that was just me
all right cool good it was me all right
anyway snip snap reveal those
bizonkers doll mia
oh wow we get to examine the left hit
all right bye hey
sorry was that a little personal
good okay that's good
well anyway i don't need to bother with
the other tit
so i'm just gonna save again i'm gonna
go
oh i'm gonna put this in my depression
is what i'm gonna do
time to slap this thing in my depression
oh no
no oh no
no
[Music]
what is that sound what is that what are
you
telling me is this part of the home
movie is this the same stairwell and
well from the home movie is this the
home move
great i'm so glad you took footage of
that that i'm about to experience so
there's some kind of crib
oh this is much deeper than the movie
suggested oh i still go
okay here's the ground great hey i'm
just bursting in here because if i stop
i'm never going to keep going hey what's
going on here hell baby yeah that's
great well too
too bad got to go down in the hole can't
look around today they've got to go in
the hole
i'm going in the hole we
[Music]
i'll take that don't look at me
whatever you do don't freaking look at
me don't look at me
don't look at me
oh you're crying
[ __ ] literal
[ __ ] baby huh you think you think
you're not tough enough for this
oh this is a little scary for you oh i'm
sorry is this
just too frightening for you oh i'm
sorry i'm not going after that baby
i don't even like my own baby what
i'm just like i know they're gonna have
a mannequin jump out at me at some point
that's what i'm waiting for
that's what i don't want and the fact
that
like i know it's coming
or something of the like and this seems
like the moment
that it would happen like in all my
years of playing horror game
this is like clearly the moment
actually i don't know that for sure but
i'm just i'll be willing to bet money
this is the moment
here we go let me guess she's not on the
table anymore
oh would you look at that i'm so
goddamn smart
oh look at this
let me just type out it'll be fine 10
million times
i love oh i thought this was like a
wooden umbilical cord but apparently
he's not
okay i'm just gonna follow this
yeah i'm a [ __ ] yeah what is wait what
is that about
i'm not gonna question it this is fine
it's leading me back to the breaker box
[Applause]
hiding the thing and then i'm hiding in
the thing hold it closer
turn off though there you go
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
i'm a [ __ ] genius i am a horror god
i am so god damn
good at this [ __ ]
i [ __ ] called that so
good and i [ __ ]
hate it yep i hate that
i hate that a lot i really hated every
single second of that
i hated every single second of that okay
so should i try to take the back way
i don't even know if it's open anymore
well i'm gonna try it because obviously
i can come back here and hide
but uh the breaker was backed by the
elevator door
and i'm assuming it's not just gonna let
me go
so you know you know you know you know
breaker box and i unlocked it and
oh look at that well that's convenient
well we have nothing else there so i
guess
can't get it working without a fuse well
i i'll take this back and i'll go to the
door and i'll put this in the depression
and then there you go
hi okay sure yeah that's that's normal
yeah
great good hey
wow wait wait wait
wait wait wait
am i back in the am i'm back in the
resident evil 7
[Music]
house
what am i deaf did i go death
i might
it kind of looks like it kind of looks
like it
kind of looks like it looks like
what is that hot
oh god i have to manually crawl under
here what is with the strings
okay well i guess i'll just
take this then and the i can't see i
can't
i can't hide i'm gonna hide i'm gonna
hide preemptively
oh what are you doing down here oh
what are you doing over there what's up
dude okay it's probably a situation
where as soon as i go out that door it's
gonna be there start chasing me back
into this place and then i'll have to
hide
that's what i'm guessing here i go
yeah yep yeah yep i called that one yep
yeah yeah yep yep there's peppers
peppers
or not
hello
anybody home
was i wrong
hello
hi
i knew it i knew it i freaking
called it god and i don't that's a
little bit farther ahead than i thought
it would be
whoa i'm gonna go in the back way so i
can see it
here we go
what is wrong with you not truth is the
right place to go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm a god i'm the best i'm the best i'm
the best i'm the best i'm the freaking
best
i'm the best i'm the best and the best
i'm the best i'm the freaking best
oh do i have time to save yes i do
i'm the best i'm the best i'm the best
i'm the best i'm the best
oh this looks slightly different wait
what the oh no it's fine
okay
[Music]
boom boom
[Music]
god that's awful
easy as peasy easy as penis
okay well that was terrible but we
survived through my
genius intellect i've guided us through
the darkness and into the light of day
all horrors are now behind us and we are
going to go into the future
knowing that we're confidently past all
of the terrors that we're lurking in the
basement
thank you all so much for watching let
me know what you thought down in the
comments below
check out my other playthroughs of the
various resident evil games
linked in the description or in the
suggested videos down there
to the right thank you all so much if
you're watching this in the far far
future
know that i've only probably gotten
better at horror games since then so
the humble beginnings of now to the
far-flung future
thank you much love to you and as always
i will see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye
you